javier está calibrando un equipo de
imágenes médicas sofisticado el manual
indica que la tangente de un ángulo
específico es 1 así es que nos están
diciendo que la tangente de un ángulo
específico digamos theta es igual a 1
que debe de hacer javier para encontrar
el ángulo te invito a que le pongas
pausa el vídeo ideas estas opciones para
que decidas que debe de hacer javier
para encontrar el ángulo bien veamos
cada una de ellas la primera de hecho
porque no en vez de ver las opciones
vemos que es lo que haríamos nosotros
para encontrar el ángulo la tangente de
cierto ángulo es igual a 1 podemos
entonces tomar la tangente inversa la
tangente inversa de la tangente de theta
es igual a la tangente inversa de 1
estamos tomando tangente inversa a ambos
lados de la igualdad y por supuesto
suponiendo que aquí el dominio está
restringido adecuadamente nos queda
entonces que theta es igual a la
tangente inversa
y aquí entonces nos puede tentar marcar
esta última opción teclear tangente
inversa de 1 en su calculadora y estoy
diciendo que quizá quizá es esta la
mejor opción pues recuerda que aquí
dijimos que si se restringe el dominio
si establecemos valores adecuados de
tangente de t está entonces obtenemos
que esto efectivamente se simplifica
como esto sin embargo hay situaciones
donde esto no se cumple y se dan si
elegimos tetas que están fuera del rango
de la tangente inversa que quiere decir
esto veámoslo acá esto sucede
básicamente pues hay múltiples ángulos
cuya tangente es 1 te lo voy a mostrar
aquí para esto voy a dibujar un círculo
unitario voy a dibujar un círculo
unitario este es mi eje x este es mi eje
y voy a dibujar aquí el círculo unitario
este es el círculo unitario aunque de
hecho no necesitaría el círculo unitario
la tangente tiene que ver más con la
pendiente del rayo terminal que con la
intersección del círculo unitario donde
se definen seno y cosenos
si es que si este es el rayo inicial y
este es el rayo terminal con el que se
forma este ángulo que hemos llamado
theta la tangente de teta es la
pendiente de esta recta la recta
corresponde entonces al rayo terminal y
este el rayo inicial se ubica en la
parte positiva del eje x podemos decir
entonces que la tangente de teta es 1
pues la pendiente de esta recta es 1
escribamos esto por aquí tangente de
teta es igual a 1 pero podemos encontrar
otro ángulo cuya tangente también es 1
podemos tomar todo este ángulo el rayo
aunque está en sentido contrario se
ubica sobre la misma recta por lo cual
si este es el ángulo que llamamos teta 2
la tangente de 32 también es igual a 1 y
por supuesto podría sumar y radiales más
y regresar al rayo original aunque ese
sería funcionalmente el mismo ángulo en
términos de la ubicación del rayo
terminal con respecto a la parte
positiva el eje x o hacia dónde está
apuntando pero este de aquí es
fundamentalmente un ángulo distinto así
es que no sabemos no tenemos suficiente
en base a lo que nos han dicho para
saber exactamente a qué teta se refieren
se refieren a la tt naranja o se
refieren a la teta en violeta así es que
dijo obtener más información hay
múltiples ángulos que cumplen con esta
descripción